which is a greeting of peace
peace be unto you and people from all
around the globe tune into
thedeanshow.com where we're here trying
to help you understand islam
and muslims and when i come back
we're going to be talking to my good
friend imam
sheikh saeed and we're going to be
talking about the youth
trying to understand the youth why some
of them have drifted off
and gotten involved in gangs and drugs
and shootings and colors and crips and
this and that when we come back here on
the dean's show we'll be right back
a little bit so they can see this
beautiful smile of yours
how are you we had you here with us
before
right and people can go to
thedeanshow.com and they can see your
biography they can read a little bit
about you
and we're glad that you are here with us
again on the dean's show
you are doing wonderful job thank you i
love the show dean show alhamdulillah
every time i want to youtube something i
said okay let me see what's on the in
the show
yusuf esther
it's beautiful work beautiful work
insha'allah we encourage you to continue
getting better and better and improving
your work mashallah thank you may allah
accept this from from all of us and
i mean may we be in the higher levels of
paradise i mean i mean
yes so uh you're still playing ball i'm
still trying
yeah yeah i was trying i'm trying nice
one of the guys he said
i am i was told and they said no no
i think you believe in a good basketball
player
and i said let us rewind that take the
belief part and let us go to the court
and let us let the ball speak for us
i heard shaquille o'neal he accepted
islam is this true or just the rumor
i can tell you what i know yeah um
a thing was way back when hakeem elijah
was playing with
raptors and also mamadou anja was also
playing with for the raptors here and
when the game between raptors and
lakers at that time and the game finish
of course a friend of uh mamadou
was also with them and his wife was
wearing hijab
yeah and of course this is what it is
and
subhanallah in that environment
shaquille o'neal came you know
vince carter was like you know he put
his guy and he said when she
comes let me know yeah so everybody all
the rapturous players were excited to
see shaykh even though they just
finished game with him but they want a
personal you know handshake a personal
greeting
yeah so when sheikhi was about to come
the boy or the man reported to vince
carter that he's here
so meanwhile shakib noted his sister and
her husband was wearing hijab
she's there so he stopped going to them
and he went to them
yeah and he gave them the greeting of
islam
the the god of peace peace yeah
and then some other guy's like are you a
muslim and he turned you know how big is
it
of course i am a muslim wow so that's
what the
guy reported but he said he was there
alhamdulillah so muslim is simply for
our non-muslim yes someone who's chosen
freely consciously
to surrender and submit to the creator
of the heavens absolutely absolutely no
one else but that unique
one god the same god of jesus moses
abraham noah all the prophets of god
and the last and final messenger
muhammad sallallahu alaihi that people
can actually get to know
from the last show that we did about his
life absolutely yeah
now you're hip i mean you know what's
going on on basketball you know what's
going on
you know out there with the youth and
unfortunately
there are a lot of youth that are
getting
caught up into some of the vices out
there gangs
and drones yeah all these other things
that are going on
and we want to help encourage them to
come back to the correct way
why do you think this is actually
happening to some of the youth let's
start off with that
well you have to understand when you're
young especially start you know when
you're a baby on your young boy
under you know 14 15 you're still
under the influence of your parents yeah
so you listen to them you you know they
ask you to pray you pray
but most of the time he's like man what
do i have to pray you know
god doesn't need my prayers a lot of
times somebody say i know you know i
have to pray but
it's too much or i don't want to pray
i'm too lazy
and as they grow they gain their
independence
yeah so they think they now i'm a man
you know i'm an independent person i'm
an adult i will do what i want to
what i feel like doing and
then those guys who are raised in
islamic environment
they may go a little bit off track then
come back
now those people are not the problem the
problem is
those the actual ones that whom their
parents were too busy
to educate them about islam or their
parents would think
by bringing the child to sunday school
for two hours
and then picking up their daughters
without hijab and we asked the daughter
to well the young girl to wear hijab at
school
and the mother you know she comes to the
message she puts hijab on
she gets into her car she takes over
hijab and this young lady she sees this
and they said well hijab is not that
important my mother is not wearing what
do i have to wear
and both parents are working most of the
time and what happened this kid
is start you know developing his own
personality which
later on will come something that is
uh issues with the family these guys are
difficult to bring them back
yeah they are difficult because they
don't know anything about islam
yeah i remember in in ottawa
this father he walks into the imam's
house after midnight
and he said you have to talk to my
daughter she wants to move in with her
boyfriend
and the question that the imam asked was
an old egyptian man
he said how old is your daughter she
said 25
and they say you you know
left your responsibility for 25 years
and now when you realize the problem you
coming running to me
i cannot help you this age wow so what
is what is the problem with the youth
is all this temptation around them
but at the same time not having that
role model to follow
or the environment that was needed for
the communities to create
for them we're not doing our job and i
don't blame these kids
for a bit but i would advise them listen
we have new muslims already being there
they saw everything they felt everything
they felt the pain of ignorance of
jed of kufu they can tell you about it
you don't have to go and experience
yourself just listen to their stories
read about them
sit with them ask what happened why they
become a muslim
and why are you going away from islam
you know are you going in the direction
where they just came back from
so minus see how these guys would be
listen chill
relax and cool down come back to islam
and you will see islam a lot of young
also misconception about islam
islam the thing is i'm going to the
ministry that i'm going to just read
and i'm just not going to do anything
and that is the wrong impression it's
not just
having fun yeah we play ball we play
soccer in
hamdulillah we have soccer league we
have a basketball league we have you
know
hog everything is there anything that is
halal
for entertainment is there yeah so you
made a very important point now the
parents so it looks like
we first need to rewind a little bit and
give some advice to the parents
prevention islam is all about prevention
let's talk about the preventive
measures that parents can take so they
don't end up
with something dangerous like this on
their hands where the youth is totally
gone
and maybe in drugs where it's too late
let's talk about this now
see subhanallah when allah
it's true everything that in your life
you know dealing with media you know
dealing with the politicians dealing
with
you know you know uh drug dealers or you
know alcohol
everything is there you can find so i
remember one of the incident from the
son of david
a mother who wants to call her child she
said sweetie take this take this
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasa
he looked at her hand and he said i hope
you have something for that
because if you don't then you're lying
to that child
and it would be sin on your book you
know what does that show
it shows that as a parent you got to be
role model
you know you don't have to lecture these
children but just
live islam pray and they will see
sallah is important go to the masjid
as often as hot as you try going to your
job and the child will see
masjid is important be honest and they
will be honest
i have my daughter she is you know a
year and a half
as soon as her mother starts praying she
runs and she grabs a little hijab
and she prays right next to tamiya
how because she saw her mother doing
this so as a parent
we have to be a role model we have to
understand number one the children are
observing us every light in realizing
that you know everything they we do
they're learning from remember the story
of imam
shafi when a man came with excitement
and he has little son
sitting next to him and say hey i want
my son to be exactly like you
yeah and the father and the father is so
excited imam michael is how old is he
he said it's just a baby he's only two
years old i bought him early
he said it's too late it's too late
and that is true two years it's too late
i met a brother in the egyptian brother
in um
in houston and he's i saw a little funny
you know uh cd player or you know i said
what is this
he said it looks like a belt and he said
that's for my wife
i said what is that for he says she's
pregnant i said subhanallah
so why does she have to wear this he
said the doctors say
take this play slow
music and the child will come
when he's born it will be calm and easy
to manage
so i took that method he said and i put
sudays
and and now alhamdulillah see
they start to corrupt the child from
that age yeah you know
if we only use those methods and say
okay well the mother is pregnant
how is sardine you know what are you
doing to make sure that the child
that is going to be born is where he's
going to be born righteous and from
there
subhanallah as a father don't bring
anything haram to the house
you know make sure everything is as a
father as a mother
make sure the child knows how going to
the bathroom as a father
make sure the father the child knows the
way to the masjid
as a father make sure that your house is
located
close enough to the mercy that when the
time of the time of salah comes and you
is still at work
and he's six seven years so he can walk
to that message by himself
as a father you make sure you are
perfect role model
when a man said to the one of the men of
the past he said to his son
who you're gonna who is your role model
and who are you going to be like
it's a you that's a child he said use
nothing but a loser boy
he said why you're praying to him i let
you read the quran you go to juma
he said no i wanted to be like i live in
abu talib and look what happened to me
i'm just a regular man now
you know so if you want your child to be
perfect muslim
aim high and then from there on you
always
always try to raise them all them by the
time they're 15 and you start
you experience some difficulties it
would be less
more difficulties than any other any
other you know child
so it obviously doesn't work if you are
lighting up a marlboro if you're not
establishing
that second pillar of islam praying
right and you might be more adamant
about following some
cultural practices absolutely then this
is not something that's going to work
now
no you you you're sending mixed messages
yeah
you know some of the parents all over
the phone you say when the little baby
picks up the phone he says you know can
i speak to your father no no no i'm not
here
oh my father is not here that's what he
said we are lying now so we
taught him from the first day how to lie
now tomorrow when he lies to us
so we should not blame anyone but
ourselves so again
we have to be role models
you know he saw rasulullah he was
everything
in the masjid he prays he is never late
for adhan you know unless he's some
something serious you know he gives a
hug but he teach he's a perfect role
model
and he's only seven years old and then
he said i want to see
rasulallah how he is at home so he went
to his and maimona and said can i spend
the night with you
she said sure so he's pretending that
he's asleep
but he's not asleep so he said
rasulullah walked through the door
he gave his family beautiful greeting
how are you he asked about them how was
the your day and
and then he saw me say is the boy sleep
and my moon is said to be allah yes he
is
and then he starts talking to his wife
even this is a lesson for husbands
you know just don't come and you know go
to the bathroom and take a bath
and then you know sleep spend some time
with your wife and
ask her how i was her day and then
abdullah said
then rasulullah sallallahu afar finish
after he finished talking to his
wife he stood up for salah and i said
now this is my time so he said i joined
him sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the
salah
see he wants to see what rasulullah
is doing as a child the child wants to
see what his father is going to do
now the parents are off at work and they
might have a
babysitter or the public school is
raising them
meaning that they're spending most of
the time five six seven eight hours
in the public school they come home they
got a babysitter and the tv is
actually educating the kids and the
music and the hip-hop and it's the
gangster rap
is this something that you seeing also a
lot and what
is your comments and advice on this
let us let me address the issue of tv
in my views when shaytan
walks into your house or into my house
and he sees tv
shaytan will say man this thing is doing
more damage that i can do let me just
you know sit back i got this i guess
this you know i hired tv that's it this
little
black box is destroyed will destroy the
whole family
and you won't need shaytan because you
already purchased your own shaytan
and not only that some of the family you
know what little kids and their parents
like yeah
you know these kids are not listening
can you talk to them so i said how many
of you have tvs at home and everybody
raised their hands
and i said how many of you have two tvs
at home
and they say i say how many of you have
tv
in their room and almost half of the
little i don't talk about six seven
years old
they raise their hand yeah so having
that thing in your room
not monitoring not knowing what the
child is watching is a dangerous thing
to do
very serious issue i'm not saying you
should not have tv
period say if you have tv get a tv dvd
player
put some you know kids show islamic kids
show but some lectures based on the
child or the age of the children
you know there are a lot of things for
muslim children put didn't show up
you know get some of the episodes and
put them together
and play them so that people can
understand because obviously on the
normal tv 90
percent of 95 percent of the things
promiscuity
you have men kissing women nakedness you
have all sorts of violence
things that obviously are going to have
a detrimental effect on
that child he's recording everything
isn't he's recording every single thing
subhanallah my son
three years old you just saw him you
know when i'm doing something
he won't even blink he's just looking at
me like this yeah and i noticed that
little eyes
are nothing but two cameras you know
just recording and reporting everything
and what if i do anything wrong he would
do
exactly and i can tell you every time
he says something wrong it's something
that he's seen it at home
or messed you in the street it's not
it's not on
his own things but you know
tv and what the children watch it's very
serious
one of the kids he said you know to her
daddy said why don't you love
mom i love your mom but you don't kiss
her like
like they kiss each other you know so
to them love is you gotta do you know a
kiss in front of the children to show
affection in love because it's kissing
all over the place
even in the cartoons everything
everything yeah so i would say
a muslim parent to fear allah because
this child
is a man is a trust and allah gave you a
gift to maintain it
and to bring it back as a righteous
individual
and that gift unless you maintain it and
protect it
and give it back as allah gave you pure
you will be held accountable
and that's what the day of you we will
come like this
our hands would be chained on our necks
and our children would say
ya allah he did not teach me ya allah
unless they free you you're not going
anywhere so this would be something if
you take away
one thing we can replace it with good
permissible things good programs
that are of a positive message message
to the youth and to the adults and to
the adults themselves what are
other some of the other practical
advices okay we we
talked about the tv replace it not with
the britney spears and the hip hop and
all the gangster stuff
take that out but we can put in islamic
programs and also now
i mean if the parents are out there busy
they're working
and now the children are out in school
they come home
and they don't have the mother or father
babysitters there and
you know how do they deal with this when
they're busy work work money money
but what good is this money if you're
not gonna enjoy it
or you want you won't enjoy the presence
of your family
i would say take certain time out of you
take certain days off
just for the family yeah take them
outdoors and make them busy let them run
get take them to the park
spend some quality time rasulullah
with his all his busy schedule he used
to spend some quality time with his wife
and his children so not only tv that
you know if you keep them busy with good
things sports
you know um outdoor activities you know
visiting good righteous families you
know
taking them to the message for lecture
for islamic event
econ their schedule can be really packed
you can make them busy
if you only really mindful of what you
can do for them
for them now those youth who are
listening and you know what
they're doing this eternal struggle they
feel what we're saying is right
that goodness wants to come out but
they're around other friends
who are calling them to the weekend
night at the party
to places that they shouldn't be what
advice do we have for them
imagine yourself standing in the middle
of a pool
that is full of urine it's filthy
yeah and you want to perform salah
and you lift your foot and say i'm going
to wash my foot
you know and then you put it back again
in that urine
would he ever be pure no so what do you
need to do is take yourself
out of that filthy environment find
righteous good environment good friends
you know
and you can where can you find your
friends not in nightclubs or you know
you can only find them as a lifestyle in
the quran in the masajid
in islamic you know muslim uh organized
events
this is where you can find them so take
yourself from that
stay pure now you can make muddle
outside
and stay that that in that situation
by being with brothers who will remind
you if you do if you look a lady was
passing when i say
allah and allah is watching you you know
if you you know
if you're my and you know not mindful of
yourself say let's go
pray if they see you doing the wrong
thing they will correct you if you're
not doing well with your wudu they will
correct you
so this is what we need they need to
change the environment and i will also
say to all the new muslims who accept
islam
don't try to go back and bring your
non-muslim friends
before you learn enough of your deen if
you don't know how
to walk just imagine this you don't know
how to swim and you want to dive and
save someone who's drowning both of you
are going to drown yeah so
stay dry until you learn what to do
and then go and help them out a couple
more points we're almost
out of time there's brothers
and sisters who are masha'allah
all praises to the creator that he's
guided them and they're coming along
but it's a great challenge nowadays
because there's a lot of trials and
tests with the opposite genders
and now the person he obviously has this
desire to want to be with a woman
women want to be with the man but we
know what islam says
about the boyfriend girlfriend thing
which nowadays is kind of odd
that if a person a boy doesn't have a
girlfriend
the girl doesn't have a boyfriend
something's wrong with them something's
wrong with them but they want to
preserve their chastity they want to
preserve this morality
what advice for them to stay steadfast
and some things that can help them out
number one the one that can help is
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
put your trust in allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and with sincerity
look and say yeah allah this is who i am
and you know what i used to be ya allah
keep me on this path and guide me that's
number one
number two you know do what rasulullah
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
number one try to fast as much as you
can if you're single
number two what do you do is avoid
places of fitness you know you can't say
you know i'm you know i'm struggling
with myself but at the same time
you being with all these and almost
unjust women
and at the same time you know watching
all these videos or movies and
what but nothing but drive you crazy and
then say oh man i'm struggling well you
put yourself in this position situation
get out of there
get out of that environment and number
three
always stay in the masjid
mr environment is beautiful why because
there is always malay
and because of the malaika you will feel
your presence
in your in your behavior and in your
heart inshallah
i want to thank you again my god
almighty the creator allah rewards you
for being with us
may allah inshaallah we hope to see you
third annual of journey of faith
inshallah next year evening
thank you very much and i'd like to
thank you again for tuning in to another
episode of the dean
show we look forward to having you again
next time i hope you got to benefit
this beautiful way of life the way of
life of all the messengers
and the last and finally peace be upon
him that if we follow it sincerely
seeking the pleasure of our lord there's
nothing left in less than paradise
and there's nothing work worth it these
cars these women and all these things
that are temporary take a time off from
the rat race of life
and really connect with your creator and
ask him for the guidance
and it only be fair if he guided you and
coming back here every week
to learn some more good stuff here on
the dean show we'll see you next time
god willing inshaallah salaam making
peace be unto you
come and see what everyone's talking
about
if you find one contradiction it can't
be from god
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best
give up worshipping god is one i will
never give up spreading this message
i hope that you take that necessary step
you don't know if you're gonna live till
tomorrow
so you gotta find that urgency to do the
right thing right now
the reality of life usually doesn't
sink in until tragedy comes
you get a few bad people the media grabs
a hold of that
and spends it the way they want to
if you say that you do not believe in
jesus you have stepped outside of islam
you cannot be a muslim is attending our
faith too
to my brothers and sisters and all you
listeners whether you're an
atheist jew or you're christian how can
we deny the oneness of our creator
the one that gave us life he's our
sustainer we've read the old
in the new testament now read the final
al quran has been sent
to mankind as a source of healing and
guidance revealed to muhammad
now it is recited by one in six people
across our sphere start your journey
here and if you really are sincere
you come to conclude islam is the only
way to go yo let them know eddie it's
the
dean radio show